[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild ich saß zu Hause auf der Couch und
habe mit meiner Frau das Länderspiel
geguckt und dann gab es auf einmal in
der Übertragung eine laute
Detonation
und ich habe zu meiner Frau schon weil
ich auch oft berufsbedingt beim Fußball
bin und kenne wenn da auch Böller auch
die sogenannten poohlenböller gezündet
werden das klang eben anders ich habe zu
meiner Frau gesagt ich habe da kein
gutes Gefühl der Knall gerade das das
klingt nicht
gut und dann gab es ja kurz danach noch
mal so ein Knall und da habe ich zu ihr
schon gesagt jetzt l bitte nicht gleich
mein Handy klingeln dann ist was
passiert
bildcheforter Schneider ist in bester in
millionenfacher Gesellschaft als er sich
am Abend des 13 november 2015 beim
fußballfernsehabend über die
Explosionsgeräusche wundert aber da
dauert es eine ganze Weile bis der Welt
dämmert was da los ist in Paris die
Aufstellung der deutschen
Fußballmannschaft an diesem Abend neuer
Rüdiger Hummels Beng Hektor Ginter
kedira Müller Schweinsteiger und Draxler
trotz der Namen kein guter Tag für die
von Yugi Löf Frankreich gewinnt
2:0 und damit herzlich willkommen bei
Tat Deutschland zum zweiten Teil der
sich um die Terroranschläge aus dem Jahr
2015 in Frankreich in Paris dreht mein
Name ist Mirko Kasimir und ich bin
Stefan Netzeband die wenigsten werden
sich noch an dieses fußballergebnis
erinnern stattdessen an einen der
schlimmsten Anschläge in der Geschichte
Europas kehren wir also zurück zur Couch
von Bildreporter Schneider und dem was
dann folgte es war ja auch noch Freitag
der 13 ich habe da eigentlich sogar noch
einen Spaß drüber gem sag wird ja passen
Freitag der 13 ja und dann klingelte
mein Handy und dann war klar in Paris
scheint es am Stadion Explosionen
gegeben zu haben da war aber noch nicht
viel klar da war auch noch nicht klar
dass in der Innenstadt gerade
währenddessen auch Attentate passieren
und da hieß es nur s Standby ja und dann
kriegte ich plötzlich auch mit hab
natürlich selber recherchiert auch im
Internet rumtelefoniert meinen Kollegen
wieder angerufen den Fotograf der halt
viele in Paris kennt und da war eine
halbe Stunde später klar da ist eine
Terrorserie eine attentatserie gerade im
Beginn und und läuft sowas hat Europa
noch nicht gesehen weil es war schnell
klar es wird in der Innenstadt
geschossen und dann kam auch noch die
Meldung es ist eben ein Überfall auf
diese Konzerthalle dort sollen auch
Handgranaten gezündet worden sein ja und
dann bin ich gegen ich glaube 22:30 Uhr
ungefähr ins Auto gestiegen und Richtung
Paris gestartet bis Frank an diesem
Abend losfährt passiert folgende
15 Minuten nach Spielbeginn versucht am
eingangstour D in der Avenue Jul RIM ein
Mann ins Stadion zu gelangen ein
Sicherheitsmann kontrolliert ihn und
entdeckt eine Sprengstoffweste der
Unbekannte rennt weg und jagt sich gegen
21:17 Uhr außerhalb des Stadions in die
Luft das ist der erste Knall den Frank
Schneider und Millionen anderer
Zuschauer
hören Explosion reißt einen Passanten
mit in den Tod der zweite
Selbstmordattentäter am Stadion versucht
am Toreingang h in das Innere zu
gelangen kurz darauf um
21:21 Uhr sprengt er sich in die Luft
Explosion Nummer
21:25 Uhr in der Rü alib fallen Schüsse
und zwar in der Bar le Caron und im
Restaurant Le Petit cambod
15 Menschen kommen dabei ums Leben
21:32 uh in der rüdü V boduel und der
Rue de la fontain rois werden Schüsse
abgefeuert dadurch sterben auf den
Terrassen des benachbarten Café bonbier
und der Pizzeria la casa nostra fünf
Menschen
21:36 Uhr in der rüdcharon in der Bar
lebelekip fallen minutenlang Schüsse bei
denen 19 Menschen getötet werden
21:40 Uhr ein Terrorist sprengt sich auf
dem Boulevard Voltaire in die Luft das
liegt gegenüber von der Plast la
Republik 21:40 Uhr schwer bewaffnete
Angreifer stürmen die Konzerthalle
batacan hier spielt gerade die Band
Eagles of Death Metal das ist die
Originalaufnahme
unvorstellbare Szenen spielen sich von
diesem Moment an in dem Musiktheater ab
die Attentäter feuern 10 Minuten lang
mit Kalaschnikow Sturmgewehren in das
Publikum sie werfen mit Handgranaten um
sich die Konzertbesucher versuchen sich
in den Räumen der Halle und auf den
Balkonen zu verstecken manche können ins
Freie flüchten springen aus Fenstern
hangeln sich an Balkonen herab hier die
Original aufnahme vom
Hinterausgang während gegen 22:15 Uhr
Spezialeinheiten der Polizei eintreffen
und einen der Angreifer ausschalten
macht sich Frank Schneider in Essen auf
den Weg nach Paris zum zweiten Mal in
diesem Jahr
2015 zum zweiten Mal wegen eines
islamistischen Anschlages ja auf der
vaterhin muss man schon sagen war das
natürlich total bedrohlich weil es ja in
Paris überall geschossen wurde es war ja
nicht nur ein Restaurant es waren
mehrere Restaurants und Bars betroffen
es war die Rede am Ende von über 100
Toten man wusste überhaupt nicht wie die
Situation ist und als ich auch auf der
Fahrt dahin war war wirklich die große
Frage können wir überhaupt nach Paris
rein fren der Ausnahmezustände wurde
verhangen man wusste überhaupt noch gar
nicht ist es eigentlich viel zu
gefährlich weil überall in der Stadt
geschossen wurde es war komplett
unübersichtlich und das war der einzige
Vorteil wir haben dann kurz vor der
französischen Grenze in Belgien einen
kurzen Stop gemacht und uns getroffen
der Fotograf und ich und das war
ungefähr gegen der Uhrzeit wo dann mehr
oder weniger sich die Lage anfing heiß
zu beruhigen aber jedenfalls es keine
Schüsse mehr gab dass bataclon gestürmt
wurde und dann war uns irgendwann klar
wir können nach Paris reinfahren und
dann waren wir relativ früh morgens da
also nach Paris reinzuk kommen war
dieses mal extrem schwierig weil es
überall Straßensperren gab und wir waren
dann aber gegen 5:30 Uhr waren wir dann
in Paris und sind dann auch in die Stadt
gefahren und sind dann nicht zum Stadion
da waren die Sportkollegen die auch das
Länderspiel begleitet hatten wir sind
dann zum bataclon gefahren und kurz
darauf dann auch zu einem der Tatorte wo
vor einer Bar auf ganz viele Menschen
geschossen wurde und auch ganz viele
Menschen getötet wurden für die
Beteiligten scheint das Massaker im
batterclan kein Ende zu nehmen nach dem
Eintreffen der ersten Spezialkräfte lien
die Attentäter amimur und mostosefai auf
die oberen Ränge wo sie Geisel nehmen
und sich
verbarrikadieren die Spezialkräfte der
Polizei suchen die Räume ab und befreien
nach und nach die Gäste ein Unterhändler
der Polizei versucht anschließend
vergeblich mit den Attentätern zu
verhandeln als es nachts gegen 0:20 Uhr
zum entscheidenden Zugriff kommt jagen
sich die beiden Terroristen mit
sprengstofffesten in die
Luft 89 Menschen sind allein im bcan
ermordet worden insgesamt sind am Ende
dieser beispiellosen Terrorserie 130
Tote und 683 Verletzte zu beklagen ein
Gespräch ist Frank Schneider ganz
besonders im Gedächtnis geblieben die
Schilderung eines Polizisten nach dem
Einsatz in dem Musikclub ich kann mich
noch an einen Polizisten erinnern der
uns erzählte als her rauskam und
wirklich einfach nicht mehr konnte sagte
dort drin kann man sich fast gar nicht
bewegen weil der Boden so voll Blut ist
man rutscht aus und er sagt das
allerschlimmste ist bei den ganzen Toten
die dort liegen klingeln permanent die
Handys weil die Verwandten versuchen sie
zu
erreichen der nächste Morgen Frank
Schneider und die anderen bildkollegen
Wachen auf in einem Paris in dem nichts
mehr so scheint wie zuvor selbst für die
die schon die Lage nach den Anschlägen
im Januar erlebt haben ja das haben wir
dann eigentlich am ersten Tag gemerkt
wir waren dann an diesem tort diese B
nannte sich bellekip und D haben wir
dann gestanden und dann war das
eigentlich eine absolute
Fassungslosigkeit in der Stadt dieses
völlig sinnlose muss ich ja vorstellen
die sind mit einem Seat rumgefahren die
Attentäter haben einfach vor
irgendwelchen Bars oder Restaurants
gestoppt es war schönes Wetter an dem
Abend es waren teilweise also schönes
Wetter für die Jahreszeit teilweise
haben sogar Leute draußen gesessen
draußen gestanden und dort waren so
Heizpilze und es war eine gute Stimmung
in der Stadt das Länderspiel liief und
dann haben die einfach völlig sinnlos
und blind auf Menschen gefeuert die dort
saßen en was tranken sich unterhielten
feierten und das war schon eine
Fassungslosigkeit in der Stadt und auch
wirklich ein Gefühl der Angst was kommt
jetzt noch und man kannte das ja eben
von dem anderen Attentat dort ging es ja
auch weiter die Frage war ja auch hier
geht es jetzt noch weiter wie geht es
weiter und es war ja eine ganz große
Fassungslosigkeit und Angst über der
Stadt das war wie so ein bleierner
Schleier muss man sich das vorstellen
die Menschen die Gesichter dazu
natürlich die Jahreszeit November
schrecklich war das wirklich man liest
ja gerne dass Bürger einer Stadt in der
Krise zusammengehalten und alle die
Fassung gewahrt haben aber über den
november 2015 in Paris muss man
rückblickend sagen größtenteils lagen
die Nerven anschließend völlig blank es
war dann später auch so dass diese Angst
in der Stadt auch dazu geführt hat dass
es Massenpaniken gab es war dann z.B
auch ja man muss sagen einfach wirklich
völlig bescheuerte Idioten haben dann an
einer der Tatorte und trauerorte
überlagen ja viele Blumen und Kerzen
haben dann dort so kleine Böller
gezündet und fanden das offenbar lustig
und das hat dazu geführt dass die
Menschen in Panik weggerannt sind und
natürlich auch durch die Handys mehr
oder weniger in eine Welle durch die
Stadt ging es geht wieder los es hat
einen neuen Anschlag gegeben und da kann
ich mich noch erinnern da haben wir
wieder vor diesen wellekip gestanden und
dann kamen zwei Autos in die Straße
reingefahren relativ schnell und dann
hat einer gerufen da sind sie es geht
wieder los und dann brach eine
Massenpanik aus sowas habe ich noch nie
ergelebt die Menschen sind wirklich
übereinander drüber hergefallen haben
sich auf den Boden geschmissen unter
Autos geschmissen in Bars geschmissen
die Polizisten wussten auch überhaupt
nicht was los war Randen dort zwischen
herum mit gezogenen Waffen mit mit
Sturmgewehren und alle sollten sich nur
irgendwo in Sicherheit bringen wir sind
dann auch in so ein Restaurant haben uns
dann unter die Tische geworfen dann
wurden die Vorhänge zugezogen dann kam
nur ein Polizist und rein und meinte
alle unten bleiben alle unten bleiben
dann sind wir schließlich noch der
Besitzer von dem Restaurant sagt dann
komm wir gehen in den Keller und dann
saßen wir in dem Keller mucksmäuschen
still in der Angst da kommt gleich
jemand rein viele fing an zu weinen das
war schon wirklich unglaublich
schrecklich unglaublich bedrohlich und
beängstigend und muss wirklich sagen
dass das das hat mir auch persönlich in
derer Situation große Angst gemacht
wieder haben völlig enthemmte
skrupellose und verblendete junge Männer
monströses Grauen über Frankreich
gebracht über ein freies demokratisches
Land in dem viele von ihnen groß
geworden sind aber diesmal rund 10
Monate nach chare Edo macht sich eine
Zeitenwende bemerkbar von al-qida ist
nämlich keine Rede mehr die
Terrororganisation islamischer Staat
kurz is oder später Isis bekennt sich zu
den grauenhaften Anschlägen in der
Erklärung werden die Morde in
korananlehnungen als gesegneter Raubzug
gegen das kreuzzyklerische Frankreich
bezeichnet und wenn Ermittler Bürger und
Journalisten eins von den Charlie DAU
Ereignissen gelernt hatten dann das es
ist nicht vorbei bis alle Täter gefasst
oder ausgeschaltet sind ja am 13
November war ja der Anschlag und bis zum
16 November hat die Polizei in
Frankreich insgesamt 168 ratzien
durchgeführt und dabei wurden auch
Kalaschnikows gefunden Pistolen
schusswesten Sprengstoff und die
entscheidende ratziah gab's dann am 18
November in S Denis das ist so ein
Vorort so bonliieu von Paris und bei
dieser 7 Stunden antiterroria kam es
dann auch zu Schusswechseln zwischen
Verdächtigen und der Polizei und als
dann die Wohnung gesturmt werden sollte
in der sie sich verbarrikadiert hab muss
ich überlegen vor wurden ungefähr 5000
Schüsse abgefeuert von beiden Seiten hat
sich einer der verdächtig in die Luft
gesprengt abdelamid abaud das war der
mutmaßliche dratzieher der Anschläge von
Paris wurde dabei getötet weil das Haus
miter wenig auch eingestürzt ist es
wurden mehrere Polizeibeamten schwer
verletzt aber zum Glück nicht getötet
und es in der Wohnung wurden dann auch
noch zwei weitere Tote gefunden die zu
diesem Kreis der Terrorverdächtigen
gehörten und das zeigt auch noch mal die
Gefahr die hatten offenbar in diesem
Apartment noch weitere Anschläge geplant
es war offenbar eigentlich noch nicht
vorbei und dass es auch wirklich noch
nicht vorbei war zeigt sich daran dass
ein Beteiligter dieser Täter Gruppe dann
später bei den Anschlägen in Brüssel
beteiligt war und das zeigt eben wie
vernetzt gerade die Terrorzellen gerade
damals auch zwischen Belgien und
Frankreich waren und welche Gefahr
damals herrscht und man kann nur hoffen
dass ich das in der Form nie wiederholen
wird und das hoffen wir natürlich alle
aber wie konnte der islamische Terror
innerhalb so weniger Monate wieder so
verheerend in Paris zuschlagen hatten
die Behörden nichts daraus gelernt gab
es zu wenig Kontrollen war niemand
vorgewarnt der islamische Staat
begründete das Attentat auf das Konzert
im batcan damit dass sich dort hunderte
Götzendiener in einer perversen Feier
versammelt hätten überhaupt muss man
sagen trafen die Anschläge keine
weltweit bekannten Touristenziele wie
den Eifelturm oder den luvre die völlig
verstrahlten krieger wollten das normale
das freie Frankreich das Frankreich der
kleinen Leute treffen Frank Schneider na
ja der französische Staat muss man sagen
hat eigentlich keine Schwäche gezeigt
aber er war natürlich und wie wir alle
in den westlichen Gesellschaften sind
angreifbar wir können uns nicht
abschirmen wie wollen wir sagen wir
gehen nicht mehr in Restaurants wir
gehen nicht mehr in Bars genau das ist
ja das Sinn des islamistischen
Terrorismus Angst zu sehen Angst zu
streuen den Menschen das Gefühl zu geben
du kannst nicht mehr auf die Straße
gehen du bist nicht mehr sicher das ist
ja das Prinzip von Terror aber die
französische Polizei hat immer sehr
konsequent durchgegriffen und die haben
natürlich in diesen bonlieus in diesen
Vorstädten das Problem dass das
Rückzugsräume sind auch für Terroristen
und Islamisten die sehr sehr schlecht zu
kontrollieren sind und es gibt dort auch
viel Sympathisanten und das ist ein
großes Problem einfach für die
französischen Sicherheitsbehörden aber
sie haben eigentlich immer dann wenn
etwas passiert ist sehr riguros und
konsequent durchgegriffen hier war es
natürlich auch so dass relativ schnell
klar war es sind auch noch Täter auf der
Flucht die in den Restaurants und den
Bars geschossen haben denn nur die drei
Attentäter von bataclan von dem Theater
die wurden getötet einer wurde von
Polizisten erschossen relativ früh die
anderbein haben sich später mit
sprengstoffwesten selber in die Luft
gesprengt aber diese Täter die auf die
Bars geschossen haben da war klar die
sind noch auf der Flucht und das sollte
sich in den nächsten Tagen auch
bewahrheiten dass die Gefahr eben noch
nicht gebannt
war rund 8 Jahre nach den Anschlägen vom
ST de France und batacan
erschüttert wieder unbeschreiblicher
Terror die Welt die diesmal in
Israel von diesen hundertfachen völlig
enthemmten Morden haben wir natürlich
nichts geahnt als wir die Geschichten
unserer kleinen podcastreihe getaktet
haben aber umso erschreckender sind die
Parallelen finde ich wenn man sich das
jetzt anguckt das Leid völlig
unschuldiger Menschen die Kranke Rolle
die entarteter religiöser Wahn spielen
kann das Entsetzen rund um die Welt und
damals wie heute ist es wichtig dass
Ermittler und Journalisten diese
Verbrechen die ganze Welt
festhalten und damit sind wir am Ende
unserer Doppelfolge zum Terror von Paris
im Jahr
2015 das skriipt haben Stefan Netzeband
und Frank Schneider verfasst
Postproduktion durch schwarzaudio Berlin
wir danken euch fürs zuhören und freuen
uns wenn ihr auch beim nächsten Mal
wieder mit dabei seid und damit bis zum
nächsten Fall euer Mirko und euer
Stefan dir hat diese Folge von tout
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Reusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Herrmann wir hören uns bei Tat
Deutschland